I'll be one
important area one important thing that
the investigators this big search and
rescue operation now will focus on are
reports that banging was heard in the in
the search area that yesterday by one of
the Canadian search claims at a P3
they've got various ways to investigate
the the search area through line of
sight through radar and also through
something called sonar boys which are
listening for sounds underneath the
surface and these sonar boys picked up
the sound of banging at some point
yesterday we don't know for how long
they heard it the bangs came in 30
minute intervals that sound then went
away and then it came back again about
four hours later at the U.S Coast Guard
which are leading the search and rescue
operation said that they had really they
have relocated some of their remotely
operated vehicles or they're remotely
operated undersea vehicles to that area
they're checking it out but so far no
results but that is one that's one lead
they will investigate thoroughly it's
it's difficult to to speak to the
significance of it but they have to
check it out
as you say time is getting really short
now about 24 hours they estimate of
oxygen and Basic Energy supplies left in
this submersible uh the Titan can tell
you that there are five vessels now on
site in the search area two Canadian
Coast Guard ships we've also got the
polar prints that is the the vessel that
launched the submersible Titan on Sunday
morning and there are another five ships
on route that includes a supply ship
called The Horizon Arctic and we saw it
last night being loaded up with
equipment that had been brought to St
John's on three U.S military planes and
it looked like they were loading up
something called a cradle cradles are
used to to lower remotely operated
Vehicles into the sea so they are
bringing clearly bringing a lot of of
kick specialist equipment into the area
we also know that a French research
vehicle should enter into the search
area by this evening again they have a
sophisticated deep sea autonomous
submersible that they could use so yes
increased sense of urgency here and the
increased deployment of what they call
assets aircraft ships these remotely
operated Vehicles as well
and John it takes uh quite a number of
hours to get from where you are to where
they think the submersible might be
[Applause]
that's right this is a this is a part of
the North Atlantic about 400 miles
Southeast of here so John's Newfoundland
this is the the closest land point to
the search area it's the closest point
to the wreck of the Titanic and I have
to tell you that you know we've seen
Expeditions and missions going to this
site since 1985. it's you know until
this point probably nobody in this
community would have raised much of an
eyebrow it has become part of the of the
scene on the ocean here at wealthy
individuals and others going to this
going to this site but it is remote and
what they're doing here is something
that's never been done before a very
complicated at rescue using very
sophisticated equipment and one of the
problems here is nobody's got all of the
skills nobody's got all of the equipment
nobody's got all of the The Specialist
knowledge no one agency has got it so to
pull off a rescue like this so you've
got very different actors government
private Coast Guard military they're
trying to work together they've got to
do it in a very short period of time but
the time is running out as we all know